let me ask another question which seems
incredibly difficult to do
which is landing on a carrier or taking
off from a carrier and landing on a
carrier so
what's that like what are the challenges
of that
taking off is pretty easy it's
procedurally
somewhat complex where there's a lot of
moving parts almost like a clock you
know you're almost on a pocket watch
some sense and you're part of the
machinery and so long as you press the
right buttons and do the right things
and you're shooting off the front so
there's like a checklist to fall and
there's several people involved in that
checklist and you just got to follow the
checklist correctly essentially yep lots
of ways to screw it up but you'll know
how to screw it up
but landing on the back of the boat is a
whole different animal
there's a lot more variables
there's essentially one or two people
responsible for the success of that
the landing signal officer
who actually represents a team of
specially trained aviators who are
responsible for helping that aviator
land on the boat
and uh the pilot himself
and
it it is a hard task to actually fly
precisely enough to be good at it so to
fly quote unquote the perfect pass you
essentially have to fly your head
through a one foot by one foot box
that's essentially the target you're
shooting for
um plus or minus probably about five
knots on air speed although we don't
really judge it by air speed it's
something called angle of attack
but generally you know pretty tight
parameters there
and you can do everything perfect and
still fail right so when we go to
touchdown we immediately bring the power
up and we rotate as if we were doing uh
as if we were bouncing off the deck and
if we catch it then
we slow down
uh and then someone tells us to bring
the power back which we do we don't do
it on our own
uh because it's such a violent
experience um you can think you're
trapped or not or something breaks and
you you bring your throttle back and
that's a very serious thing it happened
the best of us you know i'll admit i've
done it once when i first got to the
squadron um
it's called ease guns land
uh and so you know i came in the boat
and i brought the power i cracked the
power back a little bit before i've been
told to or that my aircraft had finished
settling in and that was a big faux pas
right so especially as a new guy so
um it's it's a very serious business
there's a lot of eyes on you and there's
a lot of ways to screw it up but the
physical you know rush of like having a
great pass and then like there's just
the
like the crash of into the boat and all
that the physical sensation from it you
know when everything's going great you
know it's top of the world it's a great
feeling
how much of it is feel how much of it is
um instruments how much is other people
just doing the work for you catching you
as long as you do everything right
there's a few systems we use one is
called the ball and that ball is
external to our aircraft and it's
b-a-l-l correct ball blank ball
landing system
uh which stands for something very long
convoluted but essentially it's a mirror
with lights on it and
you see the light
at a different cell
based on your position relative to an
ideal glide slope yeah so if you're
right on it you're right in the middle
and if you're below you're low
and as i add power
and maneuver the aircraft that ball
you know i see that ball rise you see
the ball low it's a lagging indicator
though right and your jet is a a lagging
engine too right it takes time to spool
up the engine so that adds to the
complexity you have to think ahead a bit
um
you know so you don't want to um
you can't just bring the
power up and leave it there you have to
bring the power up touch it bring it
back
and oh by the way your landing area is
moving not just away from you but also
on an angle right because we have an
angled deck and so you're constantly
doing one of these to correct yourself
as you go
and even every time you do one of those
yeah maybe it's a 30 degree angle bank
right i'm losing lift
right yeah and so i have to compensate
with power each time i do that so i'm
doing another one because you have to
maintain um the same level you're always
lowering like it's a constant rate of
descent that's increasing from about 200
feet per minute to about 650 and every
time you do this that's messing with
that
okay
so you have to compensate doing that
manually do it manually all right and
then of course as you come down that
glide slope uh it becomes more and more
narrow and you have to of course
modulate your inputs such that they're
smaller and smaller because they have a
bigger and bigger effect as you get
closer in
and what happens too when you're getting
close is that right before you cross
over if this is the boat right here your
table right before you kind of get your
wings over the boat itself
this big wind from the the main tower of
the boat is where it dips down so the
wind actually goes down it's called the
burble it'll actually pull the aircraft
down increase your rate of descent so at
that particular point you need to you
you know increase your power and try to
compensate against that and so that's
kind of a third variable that's trying
to screw you up on your way down
what's the most difficult conditions in
which you have to land or you've seen
somebody had to land because i think you
were also
um a signal officer as well i was yeah
that was the headlining signal officer
for for my squadron so you you've
probably seen some tough landings i have
i've seen a a ramp strike which is when
a part of the aircraft hits before um
the landing area which is
basically the round out of the boat that
is before the landing area so they
basically struck the back of the boat
coming in yeah it was just their hook so
it wasn't their craft um and they were
fine that one was kind of ugly
but it like rips that part of the
aircraft absolutely and then you land on
your bellies that kind of thing in this
particular case it hit and then it gave
and essentially dragged the hook on the
on the surface after that and so he was
able to grab a wire at that point when
does that kind of thing happen just a
miscalculation by the pilot or
is it uh weather conditions i wouldn't
even call it miscalculation i mean i'm
going to put the blame on the pilot
because he's the only one in the cockpit
but then the day he's reacting to the
situations he's dealing with and so it
may be errors or he may be doing the
best with you know the conditions that
he's been given on that particular one
you just got two high rated scenes very
common and that's when you see it with
new pilots you see it with older pilots
right new ones and complacent ones what
you see is they'll um
try to make the ball go right where they
want it in close they think they can
beat the game a little bit and they try
to and so we have sayings we teach we
teach pilots you know as a landing
technology we tell them like don't
re-center the high ball in close it's
one of the rules to live by and so when
the ball is up high don't try to bring
it back in close to like the center
point when you're when you're in close
because what you're doing you bring the
power off and you're going to crash
right down and that's what happens right
because you got the burble pulling you
down you might be correcting which is
decreasing your lift
and then you have that type of maneuver
so how are you supposed to do all this
in harsh weather conditions
and so that's the one i wanted to tell
you about that's the hardest one and
what you hear is if you hear 99 taxi
lights on
that's a really shitty day 99 taxi
lights on what's that mean so everyone
put your taxi lights on because
you're about to land on the boat and you
don't see the boat weather is so bad
that the landing still officer on the
boat can't see you either and you can't
see the boat and you won't be able to
see it when you touch down
so we call that a zero zero landing
and you turn on the taxi light so that
the lso who has a radio in his hand that
looks like a phone from 1980
um is talking directly to the pilot and
he's looking at that little light in the
rain and he's telling him you're high
you're low power
things like that come right back to left
and literally talking him down to land
on the boat right there and the pilot
usually it comes as a surprise to the
pilot delaney because he's just
listening to the voice can't see the
ball can't see the boat and all of a
sudden you just hit the boat you crash i
mean crash we're going about 1600 feet
per minute descent
at that point so you're still you're
going super fast
it's all this is happening fast you
don't know
you don't know what at
the moment it's gonna hit
so you're just going into the darkness
and just waiting for it to hit maybe
it's not dark though a lot of times it's
white into the light you're going into
into the light
and then there's a voice from an 80s
phone
i got it this this is terrible
um but so that you still
uh you still have to
so this kind of thing happens you still
have to land sometimes you just don't
have a place to divert but you know in a
sense we're trained for that because we
do the night landings as well and i
think you'll find this interesting but i
always found that the night landings
where in these particular cases
you're usually lined up behind the boat
maybe 10-15 miles whereas the other ones
it's like a tight circle the landing
pattern and so we can potentially see
the boat way out there
um
if the lights were on which they're not
but we can maybe see like the string of
aircraft in front of us but what's
what's interesting is that it can take a
while again you might be 15 miles out
and
your lights are turned down as dim as
possible
you have a cloud deck maybe at six or
seven thousand feet so that the
starlight there's no moon but let's say
the starlight is blocked out right
because just the starlight alone no moon
you can see the boat you can see the
water
but when that goes away it's like
closing your eyes right you can't tell
anything it could be upside down uh you
could be in any position
and for me it was almost a meditative
process that i had to snap myself back
out of when i was on like a long
straight away and then i would see the
light pop up in the sea of darkness
right no lights anywhere can't even see
the horizon and i just see a light out
there my instruments are telling me and
they're turned down as far as they can
go right so i can barely see them so my
eyes can adjust and i'm just staring at
this light in the distance
and it's just very meditative and it's
the hum behind you and
and then like four miles you know it's
almost like oh the light is a little bit
bigger and you almost kind of have to
snap back to it and be like i need to
like kind of like
look around a little bit and engage my
brain like back to my body and like
yeah do this because you're gonna have
to actually land well is there
just you said you don't necessarily feel
the romantic notion of the whole thing
but is there some aspects of flying
where you look up and maybe you see the
star the stars
or um
yeah that kind of thing that you just
like holy crap how did humans accomplish
all this like am i actually flying right
now
i used to have those moments on the boat
when i was catching planes land i would
i would they would trap and it'd be
night time and it's just all this chaos
in the middle of the ocean and nothing
and i would have these moments like how
the hell did i end up here you know
there's one moment in time next to an
aircraft landing on a boat in the middle
of the ocean you know
where did my life you know how did my
life go to end up here how interesting
but what i did start to enjoy was the
nightmare and goggles and putting those
on and looking up at the stars flying
around especially
over the ocean what do they look like
and there's just so many there's just so
many stars that you know you normally
can't see they're shooting stars all the
time almost every flight you'd see them
with the goggles on
so it was a great pleasure to take
advantage of
the lack of light pollution in some
cases especially on deployment to go
grab some goggles at night and go out
some quiet spot in the ship that no one
can see me and just kind of look around
you know
you